guardaci un cane giganti un vero anzi
nuovissima il che dovremmo scappare dal
negozio di animali paura ha infatti
successo qualcosa di molto strano in
questione grazie rimane successo l'ora
di giocarsi voi mi raccomando lasciate
un mi piace è cercato di oggi i
fiorellini morale ricchi di oggi e avete
visto gli scarti episodi scoperti che in
ogni episodio abbiamo degli orecchini
diverse a volte anche di cerchietti
divertente che ha ora abbiamo oggi
canale quasi sempre uguale anzi
finalmente ha messo le scarpe i
pantaloni non mi hanno mai approvato la
maglietta ufficiale di vita le promesse
io per non cattiva mente il negozio di
animali o mesto delle orecchie da
gagarin e hanno anche i fiocchetti e poi
o degli orecchini a forma di fra noi e
voi o questo bellissimo vestito rosa
glitterato lo adoro tantissimo ma ora
iniziamo subito erano 36 prum vuoi
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
non è così qua allora che succede ai
bisogni dimenticatevi dirvi se non mi
seguite ancora su instagram andati a
seguirmi mi raccomando allora che
succede c'è scritto il manager è
infastidito dobbiamo scappare d'acqua
guarda agli occhi rossi o che iniziamo
ad uscire dalla crisi presso allo
shampoo per gatti si no moriremo bisogna
saltare sugli orsi
evitarli riproviamo bisogna evitare
piano piano gli occhi e cubitali
sfracellato vi costerà questa volta
quante volte per evitare non ho fatto
niente
uno strano ok ho capito forse bisogna
saltare
come faccio bisogna voltare una pazza
non ci posso credere che ho fatto
la pasta per lavare gli animali manite
la spazzola un altro stessi non lo shock
con la pallina attenta è qui io ok che
se volete qua che cos'è questa cascata
banana medicine non è difficilissimo
come si fa tanta adesso c'è scritto
trova i due bottoni e l'impianto rimane
vediamo se ritroviamo è un labirinto qua
ti seguo questo ragazzi o no mi sono
persa fa dentro questo labirinto
dobbiamo prendere l'ultima prendi primo
cliente facile
sei riuscita qua no aspetta
dobbiamo saltare qui sulla spazio
attenta non mi devo fidare delle cose
che vanno a minare la sono ingannevoli
queste cose tocca solo evitare andare
queste strisce verdi ei ma io voglio
vedere gli animali
ma guarda se qualche papà diego cosa sta
succedendo qui la trama
e non poteva iniziare questa ma come si
fa a passare da qui mi sono accorto mi
hanno spiegato berlino sarebbe troppo
il rumor incorrerebbe tutte le palline
attenta perché ti spiaccicano con le
palline l'ho fatta ho scritto stai
attento alcune delle scale sono mortali
prova a non toccarle ok per mandare in
capito bisogna maroni ha detto ok no
vabbè riproviamo riproviamo ce la
possiamo fare uno ma che li sono portati
a secco ci riprovo eco vitale dai poi
partiamo da qui forza proviamo sì c'è
scritto non esser elettrizzato dai cavi
a queste sono le tue preferite quanto
siamo in alto nessuno fatto
difficilissimo strano che dopo guarda
macellata gli orecchi negato che stanno
aiutando perché i gatti hanno un sacco
di equilibrio io sono arrivato qui senza
sfracellarsi non ci posso creare molto
strano
cosa non fatta scusi mi sembra super
difficile
se ce l'ha fatta evitare poi non ci
posso credere ma stiamo rientrando
dentro come fare altri shuttle e qui c'è
dei peli di gatto di carne di cane ok
arrivato mi ha superato sì è vero ci
sono dei peli guardarci un cane giganti
1 ho come l'impressione che anche questa
mia finiremo nella bocca di qualcuno
questo caso nella bocca di un cane prima
parte finale la odio però non ce la
faccio allora s'è scritto questo cane
enorme ma è l'unico modo di riuscire a
scappare quindi dobbiamo per forza entra
nella bocca del cav e vediamo se anche
questa volta ci dovremmo passare
attraverso il web
se avete visto le altre spip room sapete
di cosa stiamo parlando
guardiamo dentro la buca del che allora
allora vediamo che cosa ha mangiato
perché ogni volta scopriamo che cosa ha
mangiato interessava per lezione
occhiate un cuore il cuore ma magari
sono dei croccantini a forma di ossicino
possono essere dei bisogni però li ha
mangiati interi comune siamo un atleta
attenta a non credere
bisogna saltare qui sulle ossa ok piano
piano
potremmo far ciò che dovevo solo testo
così come faccio
ok far tappa a vitale sbiascicato cui io
sono fatta ecco vi sta arrivando è
proprietario
ma vediamo ma perché mai niente
bravissimo ormai vediamo se questa volta
ce la fa a vitale sì sì ce la devo fare
per forza allora prendo la rincorsa
aspetto che salga tutto sopra bisogna
vedere qual è l'oggetto su cui passare
mi avete scritto a quell'altro questo
grazie a vita grazie dai salviamo e qua
bisogna evitare le martis noi per voi ce
l'ho fatta vitale più avanti di me come
fossi p e dai tanti aspetto a cui
dobbiamo saltare questi dei cubetti rosa
non lo so se mangiato qualcosa la porta
finale da più frutta preferita dai ce la
puoi fare
e anche per me è un po di fisiche e così
su cauzione possiamo farci le dure le
crew trek che dedicare forse bisogna
solo evita la brava corre saltando
correndo
stando a caso ma c'è ok adesso ci
prossimo è tale se lo faccio allora c'è
scritto questo negozio e un po disastro
quindi cerca di non toccare gli
immortali
ok perché io ce l'ho fatta che carino
c'è oggettivo troncare che tipo una
corda ma quella pallina attaccarla lire
lo adorerebbe lo divide creerebbe anche
alla radice corri per salvarti
scappiamo via di qua attentamente quello
che non toccano la macchina non so che
loro macchine ad ora è troppo divertente
ovviamente vitale caduto vediamo se ne
so arrivare vediamo c'è scritto siamo
riusciti a scappare dal negozio malefico
di animali divertente allora vediamo se
facciamo trovare qualcosa di nascosto
super salto
e allora è super velocità
se il male è partito un altro gioco ma
che succede è arrivato anche vitale
accarino gesù vuole
voglio vedere spongebob dov'è no dov'è
in che porta 2 mila euro qua credo che
sia questa siano così perché se si
azzecca di essere ricordate no come
fatto a cadere credo dobbiamo lavorare
su questo
club mappa di graham sulla terra siamo
infatti se ce l'ho fatta ma come prova
proverò blues che finisse dai posti così
a caso uova sulle patatine fritte
secondo termiche puoi entrare sono
fritte con la fota tigri di che puoi
saltare sull'olio keyek cadere l'olio
video volesse che continuiamo anche
queste skype room di questo video di 10
mila mi piace faremo anche questi suoi
promessi sposi bob che voto diamo a
questa skype room del negozio di animali
sapevo me è stato molto divertente che
gli do un bel nove figli dove vuoi che
voto gli data e ora mi lasciavo qua 4
casalini di cliccare per vedere andare
[Risate]
oltre al dvd ricade su quello che
preferite
buona visione
[Musica]